let me ask one last question advice for
young people you've had a difficult
upbringing
a difficult life and you've become one
of the most successful human beings in
history what advice would you give to
young people or just people in general
who are struggling a bit trying to
figure out how they can have a career
they can be proud of or maybe a life
they can be proud of
I feel like a life you can be proud of
is just one if you leave something a
little bit better
it doesn't have to be big you know
that's a life well lived right it was
Churchill who said we may it was how you
might remember better than I you make a
living by what you get and you live a
life by what you give something to that
effect
um but my advice would probably when I'm
asked this
I would tell them to ask more questions
and give answers
just just focus on being a sponge and
it's funny I asked my husband the same
question the other day I said hey we're
talking to somebody and people were
asking this and
please start a pause for a while and he
said I tell him patience
I said what do you mean and he said
I see so many young people like they're
in such a hurry to somewhere I don't
know where and that if they just had
patience and let life unfold
I think that may be a surprise where
they ended up
and actually I think that's a really
good answer and to be honest along the
way keep asking questions keep your
childlike curiosity I know it sounds so
easy to say it's just so you know
it's yeah like like you said the the
obvious things yeah I think they tend to
to be the most profound you're an
incredible human being you're an
inspiration to so many thank you for
helping uh run and contribute to one of
the great companies that bring so much
good power to the world and thank you
for putting in the hard work of putting
it all in the great book so and thank
you for talking to it this is a huge
honor thank you for doing it you did a
lovely job